i just want to say i'm not trying to say
that if you're white you can't complain
right i'm just saying that if you're
black you get to complain more right
right because
you can't
there you go don't tell the band that
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
because you can't you get this right
you can't take people's like historical
context away from them and everybody
wants us to like white people are always
like come on it wasn't us like they want
black people to forget everything
like every year
white people add 100 years to how long
ago slavery was
i've heard educated white people say
slavery was 400 years ago no it very
wasn't
it was 140 years ago that's two 70 year
old ladies living and dying back-to-back
that's how recently
you could buy a guy that's right and
it's not like slavery ended and then
everything has been amazing like it just
oh glad that's all oh yeah it just ended
like a clean where you don't have to
wipe just boom and then it's just been
parades
and presents ever since
you got it
you got to remember that if you meet a
black person they have gray hair they
remember a time they weren't allowed to
use a certain toilet so give them a
little you know time to be cranky and by
the way white people have our own thing
that we stuff that we went sure sure
that that hurt us that we have to cope
with like when they took our slaves away
that was really hard for us
and we're still
so it's pretty even
mexicans are i'm not even gonna lie to
you even over filipinos my favorite
people in the world yeah no right
they're my favorite people too as long
as they're citizens
you gotta be easy with women man you
gotta you know because black people you
know we got game naturally brothers we
know how to talk to one you know we know
how to just say that [ __ ] sometimes
african dudes they don't know what to
say they just so angry what's what do
you call yourself what is your name you
talk to me
you say i'm talking to you in the front
row you don't want to talk to me [ __ ]
you get up
and you
[Music]
[Applause]
i think that's some cool [ __ ]
i tell you what ain't sexy is that
indian [ __ ] i'm sorry
you know that [ __ ] at 7-eleven
that is not sexy [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ] ladies you do not want that on top
of you on a saturday night i'm going to
give it to you
i know you wanted your dirty [ __ ] i
know you wanted
i'm going to give you my pakistani beef
your mother
of course you get a lot of right-wing
people saying oh these polls they come
over here taking our jobs i was thinking
if a guy from poland arrives he doesn't
speak the language doesn't have any
money he doesn't know anyone and he
takes your job on the first day
you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] off
you ever notice that [ __ ] they always
got these specials about the pyramids in
egypt they're like oh my god the
pyramids in egypt who really built them
wasn't the egyptians it wasn't the jews
it was aliens aliens came down and they
were built these pairs it's how you know
mexicans are the best workers in history
there are also pyramids in mexico
nobody questions who built those
there is no hour-long history channel
special who built the pyramids in mexico
mexicans [ __ ] that's cool
there was a quinceanera i need to
attempt to have this [ __ ] up by saturday
aliens probably came with like we got it
you will have the juice this okay over
here
everything taken care of aliens
greatest workers in history only people
whose work ethic is a threat
the work ethic is a threat
you ever hear people say that [ __ ] about
mexicans
the mexicans are stealing the jobs
how the [ __ ] you steal
a job
i never seen a mexican walk into a
restaurant give me the dishes
do we
do we have to give you the money to do
you want the money as well no rub your
gloves i need route
i'll see you tomorrow at eight nobody
late
do we have to pay you more do we no
you pay me less money
[Applause]
consider this job stolen pluto
[ __ ] stole it from you
made your business economically viable
[ __ ] stalled it
stole it from you
i wish they would steal the jobs every
time i'm in the apple store first of all
if you work at apple store [ __ ] you i
don't like you
i don't like you right off the bat i
don't like it
stop being so condescending you're not
better than me fix my phone dork i don't
want to hear [ __ ]
okay you're not better than me you just
didn't get [ __ ] in high school all
right that's the only difference fix the
phone i wish 40 mexicans would raid that
place
the genius bar is ours
watch these nerds squirm what do you
mexicans know about selling max
if we can sell oranges we can sell apple
what's your what kind of black are you
and i don't mean angry or happy i mean
where are your where are your folks from
africa so these jokes are pissing you
off right now aren't they like i'm not
happy one bit about this
where are they from
sorry
nigeria okay well
stop sending me faxes and emails um
i'm
i'm not cashing your check
[Applause]
and you got an indian girl too didn't
you are you are you indian sweetheart
look at what are you
pakistan persian
how many it only takes two people i just
want you to know this
the minute you add a third person that
means something funky was happening
so pakistan
persian
and where
bangladesh
okay
everyone
how do you boo bangladesh really come on
it's it's already [ __ ] bangladesh i
mean how much
[Applause]
how did the persian fit into that
equation
i could see how like the pakistani and
the bangladesh person got together
they're like we have left india we are
together separately now
let's [ __ ]
and then
and then some persian guy went bro i
want to sell you a new rug you want
black bro you want
you want new rock bro
you can [ __ ] a new rock
okay
so i've been seeing this girl recently
uh it's black girl right she lives up in
harlem you know gone out like three four
times you know first time we hung out we
hung out like the village area in new
york you know which is sort of like a
racially mixed area
so [ __ ] was cool you know what i mean
second time you hung out was more like
midtown you know then the third time she
called me at like 3 30 in the morning
and she wanted me to come up to her
apartment right
so it's 3 30 in the morning she lives in
harlem i look how i look so it's a
[ __ ] situation
yeah because you know the deal right
basically a white dude feels comfortable
up to about like 98 99th street you know
what i'm saying
the second the streets start getting
into like triple digits like 100 101st
street start getting like a little
asthma like [ __ ] it's time to get a
little high up here
you feel that little tightness in your
chest can you feel that
106th street you're like leaning on [ __ ]
like dude where'd all the cabs go
how come there's no taxis up here
what's a bodega
i don't know what that is let's get the
[ __ ] out of here
so i'm praying to god she's going to
tell me to take the subway get off at
like 105th street 130 you know which is
like the first stop in harlem where i
can still look over my shoulder and see
like all the white people like
disappearing over the horizon you know
but she goes no man you want to get on
the uptown 2-3 train you want to get off
at 125th street like [ __ ] 125th
[Applause]
jesus christ that's like right in the
middle of everything
[Applause]
i'm gonna be surrounded on all four
sides i can't [ __ ] do this
so at this point i'm really trying to
hide like the [ __ ] tone that's
starting to creep into my voice you know
and i'm trying to ask for really
specific directions for when i get up
there because i want to know exactly
where i'm going
so she starts naming the streets i have
to go down and every other street up
there is named that's like a black
leader you know she's like make a left
on adam clayton take a right on
frederick douglass i'm like [ __ ] out of
clayton
now dude go on the internet look at that
clayton
did he kill a bunch of white people
during the slave revolt
dude i'm going up there so i know what
i'm thinking [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[Applause]
so at this point i'm really having a
battle with myself
because i'm thinking i can't do this
right i'm like i can't do this but my
dick's going now come on man we can do
this all right
just relax
pull yourself together and get on the
goddamn train right
so as always i listen to my dick
oh yeah get on the train by the time i
get up there it's like five or four in
the morning right i'm staying on like
malcolm x and like danny glover or some
[ __ ] right
i don't even know where the hell i'm at
when i see the street i want to go up i
want to go up saint nick i can literally
see her apartment building but there's
like five or six black dudes standing
right on the corner right where i want
to walk by so i'm like [ __ ]
i thought i was on like some reality
show at that point like some sort of
like white guy survivor it was
ridiculous
[Applause]
so i'm thinking i gotta walk right by
these guys right you know what's funny i
think that they were actually more
surprised to see me then i was scared
you know and i was really really scared
you know but i'm also really really
white you know
like shockingly caucasian
you know like if you're not ready for me
i can like surprise you
now especially if you live up there
you've probably seen a white person for
hours
possibly days so when i show up it's
almost like magical like a leprechaun
came out of nowhere you know
felt like i should have like a little
pot of gold
like a rainbow behind me top of the
morning too you locked it
kind of dance my way past them
but it's been going all right you know
once i get in her apartment i'm fine you
know i relax
sit down you know watch a hip-hop
countdown
pretend like i know the groups you know
what i mean
it's just getting there that's a [ __ ]
pain in the ass
but you know i don't get mad at it
because i figure you know black dude's
got to go through the same [ __ ] though
right when you go into the suburbs go
[ __ ] a white girl
right
just that same awful feeling
of just leaving your people behind you
know just less and less of you as you're
[ __ ] driving out there
probably start off lean and you're all
[ __ ] cool
20 minutes in you're driving like ten
and two the waves off like dude i like
this [ __ ]
i don't like this [ __ ] at all
there's too much grass i don't see any
rims
this is [ __ ] up none of the windows
are tinted i can clearly see white
people in every car this is [ __ ] up